this morning Russia is trying to reduce
tensions with the US over an expected
military strike on Syria the president
is still planning a response to Syria's
suspected chemical weapons attack 24
hours after calling Syria's president a
gas killing animal and saying missiles
will be coming but this morning the
president tweeted that he quote never
said when an attack on Syria would take
place could be very soon or not so soon
at all Russia's government said
overnight it's talking with US officials
on a quote deconfliction phone line but
it has no plans for Russian President
Vladimir Putin to speak directly with
mr. Trump
David Martin's at the Pentagon with the
possible US military options David good
morning good morning
defense secretary mattis is scheduled to
testify before Congress this morning but
don't expect him to reveal anything
about the Pentagon's plans for a strike
against Syria that conversation will
take place behind closed doors at a
meeting of the National Security Council
this afternoon
the president has not laid out a
timetable the White House says the
president has not yet decided on a
military option even though he has
already used Twitter to warn the
Russians that missiles are coming Oh
options are on the table former vice
chairman of the Joint Chiefs and now CBS
News analyst sandy Winnefeld expects
those missiles to come from a number of
different directions it's likely that
we'll use a combination of platforms
including aircraft surface ships and
submarines the Russians will probably
not know where the submarines are or
that they're there the head of the
Russian military general Valeri garrison
off has warned that if Russian officers
in Syria are threatened by American
missiles they will shoot them down
Russia has positioned two
state-of-the-art
air defense system in Syria but would've
fell says that shouldn't prevent the
missiles from reaching their targets
these weapons are designed to survive
all the way to their targets so it'll be
difficult for them they may get a couple
of them but in general these these
weapons tend to get to where they're
headed when if Hill says the best way
for a Russian officer to avoid being hit
is to stay away from Syrian military
installations I think it's very unlikely
that we would directly and intentionally
target any Russian forces that are in
Syria so
the way that a Russian officer or person
would be harmed is by participating
directly in Syrian military activity the
Syrians have begun dispersing their
aircraft to make them harder to hit
including placing some at fields where
Russian planes are based betting the US
won't strike there Nora all right David
thank you so much